[Music]
it's not easy butchering people sort
work physically and mentally I don't
think people realize you need to then
you know there's a lot more like me do
you think some 40 years ago your FBI was
founded hunting down John Dillinger now
we have extreme violence between
strangers we travel around the country
and teach FBI techniques to cops you
guys mind if I bother you for a minute
she was found cuffed and lashed to the
bed what people won't do to each other
there's nothing people won't do how can
we help we should be using every
resource we can talking to the smartest
people we find from the broadest
possible spectrum our criminals born or
are they formed Psychopaths they're
convinced that there's nothing wrong
with them so these men are virtually
impossible to study yet you have found a
way in near perfect laboratory
conditions hello ladies
that's what makes this so exciting and
potentially so far-reaching I can't what
these guys are about front of me the way
they view sex and women it is not our
job to commiserate with these people it
is our job to electrocute them we can't
like everything we do we're talking to
serial killers serial killers the
terminology I'm trying to warn you your
attitude is gonna bite you in the ass so
young to be ruining people's lives don't
you do you're developing a pattern of
behavior that will not sustain you here
agent Ford if you leave I can't help you
there's no procedural rule book for how
to talk to these people if any of this
is gonna work we need to talk to more
sub you want truffles you gotta get in
the dirt with the pigs
[Music]
how do we get ahead of crazy if we don't
know how crazy thinks
[Music]
[Music]